[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so a few years ago I was at the
barbershop it was my first time in there
my first the only time there so their
group of students over there waiting
their turn and so I'm intensely focused
at the mirror it's gonna like this is
trying to figure out like is he cutting
my hair right yes he is but in the midst
of those buzzing I heard a group of
students talking about college
admissions Dartmouth Williams and all
these are the colleges and I'm thinking
to myself whoa I went to this school I
could so help suggestions things to
consider all this kind of advice I
wanted to give and since now I'm just
like super excited like yes yes yes but
then it dissipates because I'm thinking
wait I don't know them they don't know
me yeah they got they still figured out
on themselves so the haircuts done and
as I'm walking out the barbershop I
freeze because all these memories come
rushing in like when I was at a coffee
shop and I saw someone with an effective
JavaScript book or when I was at the
library and I saw someone with this ap
computer science book in each one of
those times I wanted to go up in them
and say hey JavaScript that's awesome
please what can I do can I do to help
AP Computer Science data structures
algorithms let's talk I'd love to talk
about those but I did it because I was
shy I was apprehensive a little bit
embarrassed but I thought okay this has
to stop somewhere so I turned back
around introduce myself to the group of
students and said hey I'm get it please
feel free to reach out for anything I
can do to help with the college
application process etc a few weeks
later one of them did reach out and that
turned into this beautiful beautiful
friendship he's now at the skov his
dreams pursuing pre-med on the path
towards becoming a neurosurgeon so by
the way I didn't go back to the barber
shop and I figured hey I could actually
probably just cut my hair myself and
then this happened and then I'm like
okay let me start going back again so my
name is Geddes it rhymes with lettuce
one thang EJ is calm thank you all you
guys for just being here today I'm super
excited
it's
it's an honor to pleasure thank you I'm
a developer I assumes working with react
node and Java to build the better
recruiting experience for both job
seekers and employers it's overall just
surrounded by great people doing good
work helping clients like Microsoft
Amazon 7-eleven South that the Airlines
Boys and Girls Club overall a blast but
really at the barbershop why did I have
to do that did I have to not really but
I wanted to and it was because deep in
my heart I know that I wouldn't be here
today without my mentors I wouldn't have
majored in computer science had I not
been from my mentors nor would I even be
the developer that I am today had it not
been for my mentors their encouragement
their resources their guidance they were
highly highly highly invaluable and
important to my life but more so what
they really taught me was just that a
candle loses nothing by lighting another
candle you know I believe that for our
community to be more inclusive more
collaborative and even more innovative
we need more mentorship and now there is
good progress being made already with
formal programs like when you're a new
hire or you're an intern and you meet
with someone on a regular basis I think
those are great and it's really good
progress that said I'm not here to talk
about that kind of mentorship I'm here
to talk about a mentorship that is more
organic it's more fluid but that said
there are some obstacles with mentorship
obstacles that I myself experienced
greatly so by raise of hands raise your
hands if you think if you consider
yourself a mentor or if you're like me I
do like the little halfsie hand or do
like a quick when I'm quick bring it
back down and the thing is at first I
didn't consider myself a mentor for many
reasons one I'm like I don't have the
time to I'm not part of a formal program
nor do I even really consider myself a
quote/unquote expert and frankly I was
it was quite intimidating I'm like those
are some big shoes to fill I mean one
what if I'm giving the wrong advice or
maybe I'm giving too much advice or if
you really want to get to the crux of it
it was more of like I'm actually pretty
good why do I even need to or have to
help
but mentorship is important and it's a
few reasons one of them helps them you
know imagine the fulfillment knowing
that you helped someone with their
career even if it's a teeny tiny bit or
what if you helped provide one of those
aha moments with the tool or framework
or a concept I still remember when
someone explained the whole redoubts
flux architecture to me like oh okay I
see that's how that works I mean I will
never forget that day because for the
longest I was like I don't know what I'm
doing here but then it clicked
at the same time mentorship helps us as
well
it's by paying it forward we benefit in
different ways you know it's been times
I remember so I was explaining the
JavaScript develop to someone and he
kept asking these questions it was this
back and forth then before I know it I
realized wow I don't know they said ah I
do not know this you've been looped at
all which forced me to go out and go
find some videos on how that literally
works there's been other times we're
just hearing people's life experiences
their perspectives on life has only made
my own worldview that much more dynamic
and richer but more so I mean you get to
make new friends a new ally and the
supporter we're just helping one another
we reach your own goals and your dreams
all that good stuff but more so I'm a
big believer that are certain feelings
and there are certain experiences that
money you really can't buy you could buy
a lot of really good things but it can't
buy certain experiences and feelings
that really only mentorship can provide
and more so it just helps the community
I'm a big believer that what we put in
we get out it's about raising these
waters so that we're all uplifted
together more collaborative more
innovative more inclusive and it's more
so it's like this ripple effect it's
this ripple effect where you affect
someone and they affect another and they
affect another it's like a boomerang or
it's just like until before you know
just like it just comes back with that
helping return from nowhere or you won't
even have expected it growing up there's
a lot of things I wanted to do but one
of my goals is always to really make an
impact on this world how can I make the
world a better place and well I still
haven't come up with that solution that
would affect
millions tens of millions hundreds of
millions this quote the fact that maybe
to the world I may just be one person
but to one person I may be the world it
makes me realize that even if it's just
one person I'm affecting today I mean
that's to me that's that's key and
that's important and you know throughout
the course of my life I will forget many
many many things and I've already
forgotten many already
I've forgotten many names Africa and all
the places of all out of you people work
at but the things I will always remember
are those who help me those stick with
me so this is a mentorship I'm trying to
talk about people need your help and you
can help them you want to help them and
more so it also benefits you as well and
the thing is it doesn't have to be
stressful it doesn't have to be
complicated it doesn't even have to be
so involved it's more about a mentorship
it's organic it's fluid to me it's
really more about sharing what you can
when you can
and how you can mentorship is like
walking through a garden with the
watering jug and so you're walking
through a guarding and sure you can
choose one plant and come every morning
to water it or you can pick and choose
walking through this garden here's some
for you here's some for you oh here's a
lot for you and you just pick and choose
you can go the whole morning you can
spend the entire day in fact you could
go to a different garden altogether next
time and the thing is if you think it's
a good thing just do it you don't have
to rationalize justify a reason about it
just go ahead and do it as long as
they're genuine sincere and honest
intentions to try to better someone's
life I'm a big believer that just dive
in so going back on this idea what would
you actually share as a mentor you know
how can I do this if I'm not a
quote/unquote expert and that's the
thing you don't need to be and the
things you even share don't even have to
be related to tech you know what if you
could condense what took you five years
to figure out and package that and share
with someone else so that they also
don't have to spend five years as well
you know it could be about knowledge and
experiences you know one of my favorite
things I've done this entire year was
just speaking at organizations like Rosa
code sharing my experiences in how in my
journey the tech I used to ask myself do
I belong am I good enough am i
passionate enough I really like this
field and hearing their responses you
know those eyes lit up high school
junior and senior girl just talked
telling me stories of how they also felt
the same way and how they were relieved
that they weren't the only ones feeling
this way I mean to me I was like nah
just give me the one fuzzies and the
thing is perhaps you know the thing
about a framework or to service three
dogs all different kinds of things maybe
you can share that or maybe you can talk
about the obstacles you faced on your
journey to here and tell them about hey
watch out for that tree why don't you
make a left on that turn you don't want
to go that way go this way instead the
type of advice you give could also be
both general or specific I myself I
personally enjoy talking about though I
personally do mentoring those who are
both entering or switching to the tech
industry and also about applying
psychology to our daily day but on the
other hand I have a friend who just oh
man he just you could talk for hours and
hours and hours on end about
surveillance architecture and Lando's
and all of that so if you want that kind
of you just go to him I have another
friend on the other hand who just who
really makes yourself available to new
joiners when they're learning the code
base so there's different ways we can do
it perhaps you were a developer and now
you're a manager you can give that kind
of advice your experiences or your now
you're a dev from to a team lead more so
I mean I even saw someone tweeting about
performance reviews and advice that
consider when that time comes you know
I'm a big believer and for a long time I
used to underestimate the power of
encouragement and active listening and
frankly just being there for someone you
know several months ago I was helping
someone apply to some jobs and she was
very apprehensive because she thought
her background in music would be looked
down upon and I was talking to her and
we brainstorm ways and how to remedy
that
they threw a cover letter and all of
that and but more stuff was reminding
her that her skill spoke for themselves
and that she was in fact a really really
good developer but more so what I was
really doing was just listening
providing encouragement and helping
build their confidence today
I mean she's happily employed at this
company's Innovation Lab doing great
things or you can share connections and
questions you know there was another
time where I was reached out about
advice between deciding two job offers
do I take this one or did I take this
one and he's like okay you know these
are the pros and cons for Company A but
at the same time Company B has these
kind of things I don't know I don't know
get it what do you think as I'm thinking
like wait actually I think I know
someone that company a so said okay give
me give me like ten minutes call the
friendly hey do you actually have
someone who's thinking about joining
that company used to work there can you
you know give your your feedback your
advice on what you thought about the
company and so connected them both and
the rest is history
other times connections are just
resources themselves
there's been times where I've been
shared a certain book assert an article
a certain video that had quite the
impact I'm I like that frankly when I
google something there's so many like
how do I even pick and choose but when
someone can say actually ignore these
start with this one first that's big big
big big help now going back to when you
can you know we have families we have
friends responsibilities we have so many
other hobbies and interests as well how
do you actually fit mentorship into this
and that's the thing mentorship doesn't
have to be time-consuming it's an
ongoing process where frankly you're
just aware of one you can help and then
you do it for example a while back I
have a lot of interest I like business I
like psychology I like tech I like
people and I emailed in alumnus for
advice career advice and now he's a busy
guy he's a co-founder of this a startup
out in Boston and I'm like I don't know
if he's ever gonna reply but let me try
and he did and this email had follow-up
questions his
some shins insights things to consider
it was this long and the thing is we
never had a phone call never met in
person but that email had an impact and
it's because time isn't equal you know I
estimate that it took him about one hour
to write that email but on my end that
email easily easily save me about a few
weeks worth the time in terms of things
to consider what to research so on and
so forth and it's the same with
mentorship other times I think about you
know sometimes I have a busy week
sometimes I do not and so the weeks
where I have less time I leverage more
asynchronous forms of you can
communication email slack message boards
all of those other times when I have
more time then I go into Ashley yeah
please let's grab a phone call it's meet
in person or let's have a video chat
just staying flexible and adaptable but
really what I want to emphasize is
mentorship in whatever way you can
that's best for you that you feel most
comfortable with you know I am not
advocating nor saying that you should go
out and go find the mentee and say okay
for the next eight weeks every Wednesday
at 6 p.m. we're gonna meet and we're
gonna talk you're going to talk about
life and your career goals I'm not
saying to do that you can if you want to
but you don't have to it's more about
taking it one conversation at a time you
know maybe you like to write blog posts
maybe you like to stream maybe videos
maybe you like to speak at events those
are all good and the thing is it doesn't
really have to be about your job either
you know I have a friend who just E is
an avid guitarist any anyone who wants
to learn guitar he's like please send
them my way I just want to you know
teach amount of strum and all of that
he's a great he's a great engineer but
he doesn't like talking about that he
likes talk about the guitar and music
and the thing is really you open
yourself up for future conversations you
answer just one one single question you
leave the door open so that they can
follow up or maybe they don't and
right and regarding actual mentorship
you can happen anywhere anywhere and
everywhere it could be in your
organization it can be in your local
communities it can be even online you
know you remember one of my favorite
things I was going through Cora and
stackoverflow and someone asked if I
don't understand bubble sore if I don't
understand some sort of sorting or
common algorithm am i cut out to be an
engineer and just searing the
overwhelming support of people saying no
no no please no that's you can don't
don't no don't stop keep at it
just work it it'll come but then I think
about what about the flip side what if
people said oh yes please you got to
stop you just get out of the industry
that would have been heartbreaking but
seeing that support online was both uh
it was it was fantastic
at the same time I there is there's a
person in my company now whenever
there's a new joiner he actively goes
out of his way to say hey let's grab a
coffee let me take you out to lunch let
me actually meet let me connect you with
someone else so it can just happen
anywhere and everywhere so the thing is
where do you actually find mentees
there's two ways I go to them and so one
of the best ten dollars I've ever spent
around these business cards they were
simple nothing flashy essentially they
just had my name and my email address
and so then I go to meetups or events
you know I talk and then afterwards like
hey by the way here's my card please
feel free to reach out so us it was
inspired because you know a friend was
telling me sometimes it's not that we
don't want to reach out it's not that we
don't want to put in the work it's
sometimes we're shy or were embarrassed
or were uncomfortable or we don't know
who to reach out to and so I mobility
I'm a believer that we can actually take
that first step and take that initiative
so whether it's contacting your own alma
mater Zoar schools whether it's your
middle schools high schools colleges
coding boot camps they would love to
have people come in and talk to the
students like this is me this is where I
came from these are my stories these are
my experiences these are the really
really cool things that I get to build
now at
same time there's organizations like
tech job store code 2040 girls who code
all just different kinds of
organizations who are desperately
desperately in need of people with your
talent with your experiences who could
just share stories and they don't have
to be these formal commitments it could
just be one time and that's more than
enough for people to see and believe or
instead you can take this approach of
like a lighthouse and you're out there
and you're kind of just like hey I'm
over here please if you want to reach
out email me and so whether so for
example I have it on my my LinkedIn
summary my Twitter bio it's just a
little note that says and on my personal
site hey if there's anything I can do to
help you please reach out so at the same
time I know some of you are fairly
fairly fairly famous in the whole
Twitter community so for those with
large followings there are ways to
mitigate that with email aliases and
filters as well but more so again I was
told that sometimes people don't know
who to reach out to and again they don't
want to come off as rude or intrusive or
as a little too forward just helping
them know like hey I am actually a
fellow Ally I'm a fellow supporter
please reach out to me more so what this
really is it's it's a it's a communal
effort it's it's about how can we as a
community redefine and rethink what
mentorship is again I think the former
programs are really great but it's more
about how can we make it more organic
and more fluid and so after this talk
I'll be sharing this repo in this online
document that has tools it has
techniques
it has strategies and these really
contain actionable steps and all of that
so that you can get started and adding
more of a framework and more like step
by step guide but really this this is
that's just my thinking and that's a few
others thinking this really should be a
mind share a collective of every one of
what the community embodies so please
feel free to make a pull request or send
me a message and I'll add it myself it's
really just talking about hey actually
these are things to consider these are
some edge cases these are some outliers
this should this could be a one-stop
shop for those who think wow I really
can't mentor it but I really want to
deep down but but then I'm like no it's
about minimizing that barrier to entry
so people can and go out and a ripple
effect
granted I do acknowledge that mentorship
is a two-way street it's not just the
whole onus and responsibility isn't just
on us there is responsibility on the
mentee themselves granted that's
probably a whole blog post in the talk
for another day but for right now this
is more about the mentorship part and
what I asked right now as a call to
action of sorts to take this brief
minute whether it's your phone whether
it's your laptop a piece of paper and
right now opening up your calendar your
Notes app anything really and adding a
note whether it's 15 minutes whether
it's a half hour even five minutes to
think about mentorship so right now I'm
gonna do it and I hope you guys join me
as well so I don't forget but whether
it's next week whether it's tomorrow and
then not tomorrow next week I don't know
just so you remember what to do whether
to visit this repo or to reach out to
someone like hey anything I can do to
help it could be as simple as that so
let me do it right now as well
right ten more seconds
all righty see I'm a big believer thank
you guys thank you all thank you all
everyone really for taking that time out
and you know I'm a big believer that we
are like clay you know we're being
molded being molded by our experiences
by our environment by other people
you know let's say someone wants to
become an airplane you know when it's
your turn help add one of those wings
help add one of the fins a thruster a
turbine but don't make them a boat you
know we have different destinations we
have different end goals help them
accomplish theirs and it's really
embedding into our I think we really do
a good job of helping one another that I
must say I think we are a fun bunch
helpful bunch that said I think we can
always keep raising the bar for this
community be known as so collaborative
or we're just helping like hey you want
to be this what can I do to help you oh
you want to do this what can I do to
help you I mean that's the dream and I
think we can get there just little
little little five minutes at a time ten
minutes at a time it is possible so
coming back to the barbershop you're at
the barbershop a salon a conference and
event
standing in line really and you overhear
a conversation you read a conversation
online and you know you can help you
want to help you'd like to help what do
you do thank you
you